we're alive right we're alive right we
and this is the same thing I want to say
against Isis right scare me out is is
that I know that I love you guys
all right I love kalila more than you
too for sure understand all right I love
my brother I love my parents I have deep
love and if any of them were to be
removed by someone killing them or they
died you would really alter my life in a
devastating way you I would feel it it
would just change everything and it
would be the worst right why don't other
people know that that is the concept
like everyone feels that way right so
when Isis is killing people they don't
put that into play that wow this weekend
we're ruining people's lives I think
that when you're fully radicalized like
that and they're you're made to believe
that there's more to life than just now
that you're actually doing you're doing
a service for an afterlife then and if
that's what that's all you're surrounded
by an you know that's all that yeah but
the Boston bombers they killed a kid
they were radicalized yeah but it's like
you don't know that that's gonna be I
mean I guess you know people people are
missing multiple chips like thank God we
have empathy thank God that we're
sensitive people but a lot of people are
missing many chips and that's just the
reality of the world you know and I'm
sure we're missing some chips I don't
think I am I think I'm all chips like
what chips am I not missing what am I
missing the cleaning chip the washing
your own ass chip yeah but those aren't
chips dips of pretzels
those are different areas of pretzels
yeah yeah chocolate my yeah my pothole
the state of my butthole doesn't affect
the people around me are you sure yeah I
beg to differ
have I ever asked you to eat my butthole
I've smelled like butthole yeah but
that's like well I mean that's like um I
smell the chocolate chip I you know
like a turkey and then like smelling
what's going on in Syria yeah it's
analogy makes sense but yeah you mean
there are Jason yeah so um yeah that you
don't think you're missing any chips
I really don't and if you can tell me
what chips I'm missing I can maybe
address it to you right now but I don't
think I have any chips missing no are
you like I don't believe I think that
NASCAR that sport is ridiculous
they're going in a circle in a car 200
miles per hour 200 miles per hour I
don't give a I don't know why
anyone likes it but they do and I
believe that it's fun for them and I'm
gonna give you an example of that the
baseball I hated it Yeah right but then
I'd never seen a game I mean I would try
as a kid or throughout my life to
watching out this sucks
but that Cubs um was it
Cleveland Cleveland game that was
excited those were amazing okay then you
got it you go oh this is exciting I get
why people you know so I have a chip to
grow I can grow but I don't have any
chips what do you think you're missing
Gilbert what are the different chips
like what are the main chip I mean just
like what do you think is missing in
your overall character in your ability
in your just like your emotional ability
I would say to be very vulnerable to
people
hmm so you you know some people I talk
to you like you guys but just other
people their openness to talk about
their problems yeah yeah but there are
chips that affect other if you're
missing some chips it affects other
that's that's other people I don't think
I have those chips oh I see you're
saying okay you know it's like I don't
know but I'm I I do
what is that affects other sometimes I
you know you and I speak so freely and
in this podcast we think this is our
real world that we can talk about you
know like blown off penis parts but when
I step out of my doctor's office or I
step out into the real world I can't
speak like that but sometimes I do and
it makes people not so comfortable yeah
but see to me to me
that's them missing a chip that's not
you missing a chip no which I because
you know me no because I'm gonna tell
you this right now that we live in
America right and I can say whatever I
want if it doesn't hurt anyone's
feelings and about me talking about my
butthole what I would do if my if I was
an explosion my and I took a head and I
stuck it on right thank you I believe
that that's not you know I mean that's
on you
I can sit talk about that if I want to
yeah that's not me missing a chip
sometimes I have a lack of impulse
control chip where I think and I act so
quickly emotionally and then I say
things to people and then I I you know
that hurt them and then I fully regret
it after yeah I have a lot of character
defects me you don't have a lot to fuel
we all have you heard two defects I have
many of them but that's still like
normal a normal amount you know I mean I
don't I just don't think that but maybe
I'm right or wrong
maybe I do have I'm maybe I'm a damaged
person and I have a lot of things that
you're missing and these are things I
want to discover later and grow that's
the point of life you know you're right
because I find that my favorite people
on earth are damaged I've never had a
pleasant like encount pleasant but
that's it it stops out there it's
pleasant encounters with people who are
just you know not rule breakers who are
very like in the box did everything
right I find that I don't often have a
lot of things like in common with them
or even just to talk about like they're
nice they're pleasant but that's where
it ends you know mm-hmm like I like
people like people like you this was
druid thanks man you're destroyed - OH
[Music]